this is what the wave pattern actually  looks like inside your microwave oven  now obviously microwaves are invisible  they're a type of light that human eyes  can't see but if you've got a cardboard  box and a thermal camera you can at  least measure it you just need to take  out the pesky turntable once that's done  just place the Box inside your microwave  and let it run for a few minutes  the Box will look like this through the  thermal camera just have a fire  extinguisher or a watering can nearby or  something you know just in case as you  can see here my box caught fire a little  bit anyway what you're seeing are the  hot spots created by the standing wave  inside the oven unfortunately hot spots  are unavoidable when working with waves  which is why the turntable is in there  it allows your food to cook evenly my  animation is just a two-dimensional  version though